what is your idea of a perfect day today
Playa papi no one wants to play with me
come here hi hi I'm Megan Trainor and I
get to answer some questions with rescue
puppies best day ever
unlike the osteo also cute okay pull
they're fighting oh that's so cute
okay I'm gonna answer questions there we
go what's the biggest thing you've
splurged on since you became famous I
bought a Tesla they say they don't know
how they're gonna eat the papers I just
did ever myself yes I did oh they have
plans looking I'm sorry did you grow up
watching your fiance and my kids like
the rest of us did oh of course I did
the first time I ever met him was at a
party two years before our first date a
songwriting party I was at and I went up
to him I went right up to him and I've
never had done that to like a celebrity
before and was like excuse me are you
spy kids and he was like yeah and I
would yell check this out guys spy kids
and he'll yell Megan and I'd like you to
remember my name so I had my whole
fangirl moment and sometimes I told him
when we were dating in the early days
that sometimes when he laughed I would
see juni they were young and juni Cortez
and I had to get over that and now I see
a man and a very handsome man that I
love very much
okay weird Spisak video of yours is your
all-time favorite are there any that you
would change now if you could oh great
question I would say my favorite there's
no excuses right now cuz we worked
really hard on that one and there's a
lot of Me's and I got to be triplets
right and which one I would change I
don't know I probably wouldn't change
any up bass yeah even though that was a
big video I feel
like I didn't have a make up squad at
the time and I was very new to
everything and I didn't say a lot of
what I wanted and I would have changed
I think someone looks up but there are
so famous and iconic that it worked out
well
okay what is the most ridiculous rumor
you've heard about yourself that I died
got a lot of those got a lot of I'm
pregnant and I'm dead so I'm good I'm
healthy I'm alive
I sent the the passing of our sweet
beloved mega trainer send that article
to my mom and she was like this is not
even funny
do not send me this so don't say that if
I'm alive oh yeah
oh that's some sweet lovin oh hi okay
okay weird my question where worth it
what was your inspiration behind your
new single no excuses I wanted to write
a big anthem for my way back and I
wanted to mean something and I've had
personal experiences with respect and
people respecting each other of all ages
so I wanted to write a fun happy song
that was like a modern-day version of
resp ECT respect me you know there's no
excuse
treat others the way you want to be
treated like puppies you are so pretty
you are so pretty what is this face
you're a special mix look at you okay
what is your favorite memory while
writing this album my favorite memory
while writing this album is having my
family singing on backgrounds and trying
to record them and not make a mess and
well you are dead it's really hard to
focus on the questions when you got
puppies in your face oh yeah you want a
question okay sweet thang well you get
one too
okay okay here's why can you give us a
hint as to what the rest of the album
will be like an inspiration behind some
other songs okay the rest of the album's
gonna be pop pop anthems a lot about
love about happiness and
the song's about loving yourself every
song is like a dance song except one
there's a beautiful ballad in there and
the inspiration was my life and
experiences I go through alright
what are you doing we're we're come here
hey hey no fighting sir okay who has
been the most inspiring to you during
your creation of your new album I listen
to a lot of album before this and og pop
like Britain young Britney Spears would
like a she is so lucky bump thump thump
listen to that a lot love how the
backgrounds are in there and love the
vocalists all over these songs Max
Martin back in the dude that was my jam
and so I grew up on NSYNC and Backstreet
Boys I listened to a lot of that when I
was writing so you'll hear big pop songs
like that yes you will
yes you will come on in okay is because
you want this that's why you want me
okay here we go
all right if you could change one thing
you've done in the past what would it be
yemeni it's like a change one thing in
the past
I wouldn't because I'm here now and
that's all that matters haha did you
want this question you can't eat it let
me read it first
what's your favorite song to perform
live no excuses cuz it's easier than
every other song ever written
oh and it's actually a fun time which
girls guys come here I got the bag oh
look it's in my hand
okay okay which celebrity left you
starstruck when you met them Adele yeah
oh you got it in the bag don't get in
the bags hey cow hey cow
everyone calm down okay chill chill out
yeah okay your fiance Darryl's the bad
things on your new album what was it
like to work together professionally oh
it was always fun it didn't feel like
professional work he was really good
he's a good singer something's happening
here that is rated R right now are you
will are you wanna freak you will freak
oh yes baby yes come on in
which celeb what you die to have
signature wedding
Oh Lud can they be dead or alive I would
die to have Frank Sinatra you know can't
do that one
push it singing our wedding that won't
Oh Bruno Bruno come sing for me sing at
my wedding
going to your concert you know it's like
the same okay what is your favorite
lyric of all of your songs is we're not
promised tomorrow like I'm gonna lose
you that song
I'm lyric if you could go back and give
your teen self advice what would you say
I would say don't stress so much stop
having so much stress like relax you're
a kid you're not an adult yet adult life
is much different but also time will
heal all and you look better when you
get older so don't freak out you know I
think we did it kids if you wanna adopt
these amazing sweet puppies go to North
Shore Animal League America that's all
you're for - and you could take you're
excited you wanna hold
[Music]